watch the silver eye on top of the are  just watch every time it swings let's  pretend we're unraveling a piece of  string  little by little let's pretend that  piece of string is time unraveling  minute by minute second by second going  backwards time slipping away everything  around you this house my voice your  mother all these things are getting  further away we're going back through  your life  back to when you started school when you  first learned to walk when you were just  a baby back to the day you were born  back to the time before this model I'm  no longer speaking to miles I'm speaking  to the person who has taken residence  inside his body  he came uninvited tell me if you can  hear my voice  my ass  miles what's wrong mommy I'm scared come  here baby  [Music]  you